thank you Andy and thanks to all the
organizers especially you in song for
arranging such an excellent meeting I'm
going to talk today about three topics
related to the work done in my lab on
the Neanderthal genome project this is
of course a very large collaborative
project headed by Svante Paabo and David
Reich and involves many other people I
will focus on things that we were done
primarily in my lab one published and
two unpublished they first recently
there was this paper of a Neanderthal
fossil found in the Denis of a cave in
the Altai mountains here it's the same
cave from which the Denis 'va fossil was
found but at a slightly lower stratum
this turned out to be very very high
quality fossil allowed sequencing to a
depth of 52 or 53 X and nearly at the
sink complete coverage of the single
copy DNA but many many interesting
things about this the the genome
sequence from this fossil I will focus
on one that we were most involved in
when hengly and and David were doing
their analysis using PSM C to try and
try to infer the the demographic history
of the population from which this fossil
came they noticed that there were long
appeared to be long runs of homozygosity
suggesting that this individual was
highly inbred and so flora Jay a postdoc
in my lab and and I took on the project
of decided trying to understand it more
detailed exactly what the ingredient was
in the in the ancestry of this
individual and there were a number of
technical issues that flora had to
resolve one of them was to decide
exactly how you call a run of
homozygosity if you require perfect
homozygosity then you will sequencing
error
error and other other issues will
produce what appeared to be heterozygote
sites in the middle of long runs
breaking up what what it seems obviously
a long run into several shorter runs and
so quite a bit of simulation effort on
Flora's part went into deciding exactly
what criterion to use to call around of
homozygosity once she arrived at that
criterion and also you have to deal with
missing data and other issues and then
indeed we found that there were a number
of very long runs of homozygosity here
are two chromosomes with showing only
runs of homozygosity longer than 2.5
sentiments where we just estimated the
distance Incentive organs by converting
megabases
in descendant Morgan's we did not put
this on a real recombination map and you
can see for example two things here on
chromosome 8 there were many of these
shorter runs of homozygosity compared to
what we saw in the denisa van genome and
what we saw in a high coverage PAP high
quality Papo and genome that david's
group and sequenced and this was typical
of what we saw on the other chromosomes
in the diff in addition there were many
very long runs this is the stretches
more than 40 centimeters and so we
concluded two things from preliminary
analysis one is that there was well
there's obviously a lot of inbreeding in
this individual but there may well have
been two kinds of inbreeding there was
inbreeding due to a very recent common
ancestor incest in the Ice Age but there
was also inbreeding possibly due to
population structure or more we don't
know the cause of course but there may
have been what we call background
inbreeding so in addition to have an
immediate common ancestor or two there
was more distant common ancestors and so
to
to to sort this out the first thing we
did was look at the distribution of the
lengths of homozygosity fragments we had
called this homozygosity by descent and
compared this to the denise oven and the
altai genome notice the scale is very
different so in the Altai genome in the
denise of a genome there's only one
round of homozygosity greater than ten
sentiments here there were many more 17
16 or 17 in addition there were more
shorter runs the the graph doesn't show
that as clearly so we this was so it was
obviously inbred about 13% of the genome
was in runs of homozygosity greater than
5% of organs and so flora did then a
number we tested a number of family
structures all the possible family
structures that could lead to the level
of inbreeding we thought was appropriate
for this individual and to separate the
the recent from the background
inbreeding we focused on first on tracks
that were longer than 10 sentiments
because those were those could only be a
product of recent inbreeding or at least
the number we saw could only be a
product of recent inbreeding and she
simulated these various family
structures all of these have inbreeding
coefficients of 1 8 and the asterisk
means asterisk means also grandmother
grandson or aunt and nephew these are
avuncular marriages here we considered
full siblings and then half uncle and
niece and first cousins these have an in
breeding coefficient of 1/16 and these
have inbreeding coefficient or
relatedness of 1/4 1/16 and 1 1/2 and so
with with these simulations she could
match the data the number of runs of
homozygosity and the total coverage of
the runs of homozygosity for these long
runs with any of these
families meaning that the in breed most
likely that the inbreeding coefficient
of this individuals was 1/8 but we could
not distinguish between any of these
family structures even though we are
quite aware they involve different
numbers of common ancestors and
different numbers of meiosis separating
going down the different pathways so
it's not that we didn't try it's just
that we we tried the recombination in a
few generations is so so stochastic that
you don't get a clear a clear signal
that allows you to distinguish this at
least using the methods that we have
remember we don't have allele
frequencies in the population to to use
that information we think it's very
unlikely that the parents were full
siblings and it's also very unlikely
they were first cousins but we can't
absolutely exclude these so but
undoubtedly there was very recent
inbreeding and that's what this
conclusion section says with some
qualifications we then looked at the X
chromosome and found it at least one run
of homozygosity greater than 10
santé Morgan's I think it was 16
centimorgans meaning that the X
chromosome itself was inbred and if you
remember your basic genetics that allows
you to exclude certain families that
could lead to an in breeding coefficient
of 1/8 the most obvious one is you can
exclude this family where these parents
are half siblings with the father in
common the reason is that the X is not
transmitted down both paths so you could
not have an in breeding coefficient on
the X that's the same as the autosomes
if they if the parents were full sibling
half siblings then it's the mother not
the father in common and there are some
other more obscure ones but this was the
most important
so with in addition to the the recent
inbreeding we always as I say we
suspected that it was back that there
was background inbreeding and to look at
the background inbreeding we analyzed
the coverage for tracks in the range two
point five to ten sentiments remember
that recent inbreeding was based on the
ten centimorgan and over so we're not
reusing information and what farah found
is that once you subtract the expected
inbreeding coat the expected number of
tracks in this range attributable to
recent inbreeding there were way too
many to be a consistent with the
assumption that there was no other
inbreeding so if there was no other
inbreeding these these lines would be
down here but under any of the family
structures the expected number once we
subtract the expected number of tracks
in this range attributable to recent
inbreeding we have too many left over so
we concluded from this analysis that not
only was this individual bred highly
inbred because of her recent family
structure but there was background
inbreeding of some kind
now that background inbreeding could
either be that the parents were
themselves somewhat inbred so in the
fact the family structure in this family
structure for example these two males
were themselves close relatives and had
a common ancestor up here or the mother
was somewhat inbred that is you had not
only a recent common ancestor but more
distant common ancestor so that's one
possibility the other is that there was
simply a very small population so
everybody was somewhat inbred and we
couldn't distinguish between those flora
had a very difficult time finding a
scenario of successive bottlenecks and
constraints on the population size which
gave us
the level of background inbreeding that
we observed in this individual but she
couldn't exclude the possibility that
there was some purely demographic cause
for it
so that was background injury inbreeding
we don't know exactly why to answer a
question that I was asked a number of
times is this wide Neanderthals went
extinct the answer is I don't think so
it's more a sign that they were a small
population which the PSM see analysis
also showed and had been a small
population for a long time but I think
that was a symptom of the the problems
that they faced from climate or
competition or just plain bad luck
rather than the actual cause of the
cause of their demise once you say that
reporters lose interest in a hurry I'm
talking to you so here's the background
inbreeding that's our conclusion and
that's all I'm going to say about the
inbreeding story second part of what
I'll talk about is new work done by
Fernando Rossi Moe who's here someplace
I hope yes there he is and this is we
wanted to use the information from the
Altai genome the Denyce of a genome to
look for selective sweeps in modern
humans and this is something that people
have been number of people have been
concerned with we wanted to see if there
were methods for analyzing the data
which took account of the niandra
information from the Neanderthal genome
in addition to the more conventional
methods of analyzing for selective
sweeps of the kind done by number of
people here including Chuck and Molly
and Wolfgang and Rasmus and others so
there's a lot of work on selective
sweeps what we're trying to do is add
information from the Neanderthal so and
so the idea is we had of course modern
humans we focused on sites that were
fixed arrived in mod
humans and fixed ancestral in
Neanderthals and Denisovans because they
seemed like good candidates for and also
sites that were in interesting regions
in coding regions or regulatory regions
or splice site regions and so on and if
they're fixed in all modern humans they
had to have been fixed before this the
the separation of modern humans into
different geographic groups and we
wanted to be able to detectives detect
hard selective sweeps that arose very
early in the history of modern humans so
they could go to fixation by this time
or possibly even were fixed alleles that
were in low frequency in the common
ancestor and then increased in modern
humans and the the currently available
methods the method used by Hernandez at
all and other other studies of selective
sweeps in humans have as they say they
have the range of about 10,000
generations of the sweep has finished
more than 10,000 generations in the past
I believe there's no power using
currently available methods to detect
those sweeps we want so I will call
things that sweeps that finished more
than 10,000 generations in the past
ancient sweeps and so what we did was
use some summary statistics which are
designed to target these ancient sweeps
one is a measure of heterozygote well
that's it but let me go back the idea of
to detect an ancient sweep one thing any
one thing a selective sweep does is
derive a ancestral haplotype to a high
frequency we all know that that comes
from a Hagin Maynard Smith but then
after its sixth you have a very close to
the selected site you have homozygote
you have the single haplotype fixed and
then you can start to accumulate
mutations Noom you
patience that arose after the sweep was
completed it doesn't always happen but
if it does happen what you will produce
is a very distorted frequency spectrum
of haplotypes and so we focused sights
sets of four of select of segregating
sights sets of four segregating sights
near these candidate sites that we were
concerned with so if those sights had
been driven - if there was a high
frequency haplotype for those sites then
evidence of the past selective sweep
might be in the frequency of the most
common haplotype something dick Hudson
looked at many years ago or the presence
of a lot of rare alleles so it is
basically a distortion of the frequency
spectrum as seen from the perspective of
the haplotype and so measured like this
which this isn't PI this is the hetero
zygosity of the four sites that we are
considering and we've used a sliding
window but this would be low if those
sites were in low frequency the
segregating sites were in had a low
frequency allele and then also the these
are of course highly correlated the
frequent haplotype frequency
distribution would be skewed because you
would have one common haplotype and a
lot of rare haplotypes and then finally
we tried to include information from the
the Neanderthal genome the nice of a
genome in the following way we if a one
thing a selective sweep can do it can
take a haplotype that's initially rare
and drive it to high frequency I mean
most likely the haplotype this
advantageous allele is on will be
thicker one of the common haplotypes you
just get the luck of the draw but there
is the capacity to take a haplotype
that's initially rare and drive it to
high frequency and make it the most
common haplotype if that happens
then the that haplotype was initially
rare
it was probably rare it will probably be
rare in the Neanderthal genome as well
so you would have the most common
haplotype not present in the Neanderthal
genome with a slightly higher frequency
of there were a past selective sweep an
ancient sweep now of course we don't
have phase relationships in the
Neanderthal genome but we could ask what
we did have phase data we use the the
thousand genomes phased data we could
ask is the haplotype that's in high
frequency for four base pairs consistent
could it possibly be one of the help
they've me and earth all haplotypes so
if it could possibly be one of the floor
with any permutation of the Neanderthal
then you'd say yes it's consistent if
it's inconsistent then you'd say it's
inconsistent if there's no way for it to
be the one of the Neanderthal haplotypes
so we had an index of consistency which
was either one or zero we didn't try to
say how consistent or how inference
system and then Fernando did a large
number of simulations just looking at
the properties of these four test
statistics as a function of the time
since the selective sweep was finished
so this is thirteen thousand nine
thousand five thousand one thousand
generations this is really the ancient
sweep column and looking at the the
properties of the four test statistics
this is the majority haplotype this is
the index of evenness this is the hetero
zygosity and this is this index of
consistency and you can see that for
example the the evenness doesn't show
much of a signal for an ancient sweep
the majority haplotype doesn't the the
hetero zygosity this computed hetero
zygosity shows a little signal it's it's
it's there it's not just a printer error
and the in consist
he surprisingly shows a substantial
signal even for a sweep that finished
thirteen thousand generations in the
past so this gave us some hope that they
even using these test statistics without
doing anything really hard could provide
some information about selective sweeps
but is it normalized by the okay so the
next thing we did was thank you like
intuitive explanation for why it's the
signals lasting there I mean are the
recombination rates so low well these
are four adjacent for adjacent
polymorphic sites so how close other
Jason they look like they were within
and came within 10 KB so the first thing
we asked is is there any power to inject
neutrality just using one of these test
statistics on its own and they and they
these were scaled in different ways H
Prime and H double prime are two
different scaling one they're scaled
partly using the differentiation of
those four from the chimp genome and
partly using the distribution and the
standard deviation sample for untoward
for regions not near the selective site
and we found if selective's if the
selection was strong and the so s is
point O one of the suite finished 13,000
generations in the past then there was
some power even using just one of the
indices so H double prime is a is a
scaled version of this compatibility
index this is a slightly different
scaled version not as good there's some
power in 20-25 percent power it's not
great it's not what we had certainly
hoped for but it's better than nothing
at least we thought it was better than
nothing with weaker a weaker Silla and
it does have considerable power for
sweeps that finished in this 5,000 to
10,000 rain which was already hard to
hard to detect so it wasn't it I says it
wasn't as good as we had hoped for but
it's better than it could have been with
weaker selections selection sweep of
0.01 a selection coefficient of 0.01
then we really don't have any power to
detect ancient sweeps my argument is
that these are the sweeps that were
really interested in the ones that were
driven by whatever new conditions humans
experienced early in the after they's
the separation from Neanderthals
so then Fernando looked at did as an ABC
analysis approximate Bayesian
computation analysis using all four
indices together the H double prime
version and simulated various sets of
under different sets of parameter values
and group the outcomes by the Bayes
factor that allowed that separated
neutrality from selection and so with a
bit using a base factor of five and a
selection coefficient of 0.1 we could
dispute rolla Tia bout forty percent of
the time if there really had been a
selective sweep of that type so we were
we were we were fairly pleased with this
and for weaker selective sweeps it
doesn't we don't have nearly the same
power in this range although we have
considerable power in this range and
when you simulate neutrality very nicely
we don't get much of a signal of
selection that's also convenient
so then Fernando applied this to the
data from the need from the Neanderthal
genome paper the Altai paper that I
showed you with this number of sites
these are recited the sites of each
category that were fixed in modern
humans and ancestral in Neanderthal and
Denis ovum unfortunately for us we
didn't find a strong signal
selective sweeps in any of these
categories there were some individual
sites that had significant Bayes factors
but like the Hernandez at O paper we did
there was no difference in synonymous
and nonsynonymous nonsynonymous
substitutions in coding regions making
us suspect that well either there's a
lot more selection on synonymous sites
than previously supposed or a lot less
selection of this type on nonsynonymous
sites so I I would agree with their
conclusion that hard sweeps are very
very infrequent in the history of modern
humans the one exception is that for
splice sites there is a consistent
signal of ancient selective sweeps that
we can we do reject native neutrality
for them more than for other for other
types of changes whether that means
something we don't know
so with this analysis
Fernando then these are the sites that
had a Bayes factor greater than five and
favor of selection and also a good fit
to a model of selection some of three or
four of them are non synonymous several
splice sites and some other sites in the
regulatory region so and again what this
means we're not completely completely
sure so that's the that's the second
part of my talk the third part is work
that's not published and not not even
completely finished it's being done with
Melinda Yang who is also here someplace
back there yes trying to go slow in the
seat as possible
we call this projection analysis and it
started it doesn't it didn't start from
the the Neanderthal genome project it
started from another project that we're
collaborating with David and and
Johannes Krauss on the genome sequence
of a fossil a thousand-year-old modern
human fossil from the washboard cave the
manuscript describing that work was just
put on the archive a few months ago this
work didn't go into that paper but it
was motivated by it because the quiet
and that the question is suppose you
have a genome and you know nothing about
it you just get a sequence from the sky
and that's what the washboard genome was
we didn't know what it was it was just
something it was a genome but you do
have populations that you know a lot
about you have thousand genomes data and
so you would like to know in some sense
the relationship between the single
genome and I'll try to be consistent and
call that the test genome and one or
more populations and I'll describe only
one population at a time and say well we
have a reference population and you can
think the thousand genomes European
African Asian population or some other
population that you happen to have
sequenced you know a Drosophila
melanogaster or Drosophila pseudo
obscura or some reference population and
you would like to just see the
relationship and I and I view this work
this method more as exploratory data
analysis then I did certainly not a
method of estimation or hypothesis
testing at least yet and it may never be
but it leads to some interesting ways to
think about data and that's and so I
will describe what we've done in that
regard so you take every polymorphic
site in your reference population so you
have you computed your frequency
spectrum you know every the allele
frequency at every reference site every
site in the reference population
forever segregating site now you go to
the test genome and you say what does
the state of the test genome if it's
homozygous ancestral then you give a
weight 0 W was the weight you assigned
to that in the test genome if it is
heterozygous then you give a weight 1
over 2 X where X is the frequency of the
derived allele in the reference
population and if it is homozygous
derived
you give it a weight 1 over X it seems a
very curious thing to do it will soon be
obvious why I'm doing this and then you
collect all the sites in the test genome
which have the same frequency of X and
the reference population and you compute
the average weight and I will call this
average weight W bar of X the projection
of the test genome onto that reference
population if you have a different
reference population you get a different
projection if you have a different test
genome and the same reference population
you get of course a different projection
now the reason I say maybe it's obvious
to all of you already why I did it this
way why we did it this way if the test
genome is a random sample from the
reference population the projection is
one independently of X and and this is a
one example of what I call Felson steins
law everything that's true is obvious
and this comes from years of explaining
things to Joe I have some think I have
some new nice result and I explain it
they listens very patient when he says
oh well that's obvious it's because
that's fells and Stein's law so it I
think and I think it will be obvious
that the the projection of a population
onto itself is one if the relationship
between the test population that is the
population where the test genome came
from and the reference population is
represented by this tree where there was
a clean separation tau generations in
the past
then work that I had done years ago with
watch n we'll just modifying the algebra
a little bit shows that the projection
decreases exponentially with tau over 2
n this is if all the populations are of
constant size but is still independent
of X so there's a line and it just
settles down at a rate that depends on
the on the time of separation that's
slightly less obvious but it it doesn't
take long to agree with that ok now so
now we have start to ask about more
interesting demographic events suppose
there was a bottleneck in population
size in one of these populations how
will that project how will that affect
the projection well we did we now we
couldn't do any more analytic theory
although I should say at this point what
we're doing is really looking at one
aspect of the joint frequency spectrum
of these two populations and what what
and this is very close to what Mick
Patterson will talk about in his talk
where he has a very very sophisticated
useful analytical method of studying the
joint frequency spectrum well we we
didn't use that we used the Ryan Gooden
kunst program daddy not for that not the
inferential part but we used it to solve
the couple diffusion equations but we
it's consistent with with results we got
from simulating doing coalescence
simulations okay so remember the
question is what happens with a
bottleneck
you have a bottleneck in the test
population the projection is still flat
we assume here all the parameters are
motivated by the Neanderthal example so
the time of separation of 60,000 years
population sizes 10,000 25 years per
generation and we assumed a a bottleneck
reduced the population size by a factor
of 10 for a period of 30,000 years and
this is roughly consistent I mean it's
at the same order of magnitude
the bottlenecks indicated by the PSM see
analysis so there is I mean these this
wasn't meant to reproduce human history
but there we're trying to give it a
certain truthiness as people used to say
if there was a bottleneck in the
reference population there's a
distinctive signature of that and if
there's a bottleneck and the test and
reference of course you get the same
signature if there's a bottleneck in the
common ancestral population you get a
slightly different pattern in the in the
projection X is the frequency these snip
frequency in the reference population
now now now it's in the thick thousand
genomes think European thousand genomes
population so you measure this and then
you query the test genome to see what
the state of all the segregating sites
are no it's it's the contribution it's
the average of W for all the segregating
sites averaged over the test genome okay
so now we come to a question of gene
flow and the direction matters and we
calculated the effect of gene flow here
is the the roughly the Neanderthal
admixture rate about 50,000 years ago we
also considered a twenty thousand year
period of admixture of one-way migration
from the from the the test to the
reference if there's admixture from the
test into the reference that is from
Neanderthals into modern humans then you
get an elevation of the projection if
there is migration the other way for
only from the reference into the test
there's no effect and there is no
difference we adjusted the parameter so
that there's no difference between a
prolonged period of gene flow and of a
single pulse of gene flow
at a specified rate I'd actually thought
there might be a way to distinguish the
two but obviously there isn't okay and I
wanted to ask specifically about this
situation here where you have a
bottleneck in the reference population
you have no bottleneck in the test
population and you have recent admixture
into the reference population by recent
I mean ten thousand years ago
so just to these if there's no
bottleneck this is gene flow ten
thousand years ago if there's no
bottleneck there's only a very slight
effect on the projection if there's no
migration then this is a curve I showed
you before but the combination of a
bottleneck and the reference and a
little bit of recent gene flow gives you
a substantially elevated projection now
the last blast case I will consider is
one where there's a reference population
a test population and another population
from which you do not have a sample or
at least you're not considering that
sample and I'm using Peter bier Lee's
term of ghost population to represent
the thing you have not sampled which is
influencing the things you have sampled
and the ghost could add mix with the
test population with the reference or
with the common ancestor or it could may
I actually we actually consider the case
where do add mixes with both the test
and the reference at the same time now
if the ghost if the ghost ad mixes with
the test population only it has a very
slight effect on the projection you can
see that this line is the theoretical
expectation and it's slightly below it
but it's essentially flat if the ghost
population goes into the reference ad
mixes with the referent population or
the admixture though you get a
depression of all these alleles and
frequencies that are low but not too low
and that was interesting to us because
there are there are a number of cases
where there is a claim of ghost
admixture and we wanted to look a little
more at this to see if the ghost ghost
admixture into the reference that's the
one that produces the most important
effect followed by recent admixture into
the test coffee from the test into the
reference so think for example the ghost
could be Neanderthals and mixing with
the ancestors of Europeans we think that
happened and then the test could be
admixture from African populations into
the Europeans in the recent past and if
you allow for a bottleneck in the
reference population plus the recent
admixture plus the admixture from the
ghost population then you get a
substantial effect you don't have a
depression in the low frequency alleles
created by the ghost admixture because
the recent admixture and the bottleneck
swamped that out and we were curious
about that yes the reason reason we were
curious about that is that we have a
situation where we if you only look at
modern human populations if you look at
Africans as the test population and
Europeans us the reference from the
point of view of those populations there
is ghost admixture from the Neanderthals
and so one of our questions was could we
see the ghost admixture without having
the Neanderthal genome and we could also
test the hypothesis that Geoff wall and
others have proposed that there was
ghost admixture in an African population
from a population we really don't have a
an archaic population we really don't
have evidence of though here's some data
analysis now one thing that puzzled us
there's all of this is using the
thousand genomes ceu population and then
the test genomes were
high-coverage high-coverage genomes that
David Reich's group sequenced as part of
the Altai and denisa the papers these
were the a a panel genomes if you'd
sample a French and using the French
genome you get the expectation I mean
it's the European except that you get
this little dip here and we don't know
if that's well we just thought we don't
have the explanation for it if you use
the Han you get a signal of a little bit
of admixture the Pappa when you get a
more complex signal and all of the
Africans show projections that look like
this which coincidentally not
coincidentally we arranged it to look
this way look like this so we expect we
our conclusion is that even though this
should in principle show a signal of
ghost admixture that is Neanderthal
admixture into the Europeans that is
swamped by recent gene flow recent
genetic exchange between Africans and
Europeans without assuming something
like that it's very hard to find
consistency with the data well this is
this is the data no no okay the Africans
into the European told
it's from the Africans into the
Europeans that as you need okay you need
admixture both ways but you don't need
it both ways you need African to
European admixture sometimes after the
European bottleneck did you try North
African populations
no we don't we don't have any of those
okay well we have some more deputies
Cornell was sitting inside to say Oh God
wait here so here's the data interesting
with washboard this was the motivator
for all of this has the same dip it
looks like a random European which is
why we didn't try to get this in the
wash board paper the Altai and the Denis
ofin remember this is the European
reference they do show a strong signal
of admixture the lower level of the
Denisovan is because of the separation
of denisa than of Neanderthal and I'm
running out of time so I will I won't
elaborate on that now when you use the
your the African the Aruban is the
reference population and look at the
projection of Europeans Asians and pap
ones on the African population you do
see this dip that we at least found was
consistent with admixture from an art
from another source from a population
not represented by a sample so this I
would say this is consistent with what
Geoff and others have said that there is
evident and it also I believe has
reached this conclusion there is
evidence of admixture in African
populations from an archaic population
and we don't this method isn't going to
tell us much more about that archaic
population here this is just for
completeness the washboard genome also
shows that signal and there is a signal
of denisa van and Altai admixture in
Africans which again I think is
consistent with recent admixture between
Africans of Africans and Europeans but
this time it has to go from Europeans to
Africans so there has been some exchange
I think the assumption of no exchange
is not consistent with our analysis okay
so that's all I have to say thank you
yes Molly
well I think all the sites we looked at
we're like that they were all fixed in
modern humans and ancestral intervals as
Fernando
sitting beside yes so I'm curious right
every I I tend to have a knee-jerk
reaction against new summary statistics
because you know there are lots of
different scenarios that one we could
come up with
they're like baby pictures right much
better than anybody else so
is there a sort of goodness-of-fit test
or something that one could do to
compare scenarios and see or other data
we are we are doing that the question
for us is Lisi was like a feminist hey
this is like very logical to test accuse
and one could imagine thinking about
other ways right we haven't the question
we haven't yet answered is is this a
better way to look for parameter
estimation that's simply using daddy or
using 8-bit sort of once a ml daddy yes
it's like a one-sample daddy I mean I I
find it hard to believe that you would
do better using the projection if you
have the whole you have a bunch of
genomes from the test population avila
compiling and analyzing them wants them
to come on at the time I think it's much
more appropriate when you have a single
genome and that's all we've got
yeah then I think that's it as I said
that's why that was the motivation but I
thought since we were in the
neighborhood
because some kind of sub structure and
perhaps the the Dean cap initiative
thing is maybe some coming from so well
it's we saw the same signal what we
don't we don't really know because we
don't have a population of sign to test
for that in the song but to get the
patterns we saw you have to have the
ghost add mixtures of the ghost
population diverged substantially before
the European and African population so I
don't it isn't consistent with that
mixture say between Sun and you know no
I mean I think the Safa was the only
other species for right now where you
have David of this entire know we've
tested it a lot on simulators but that's
we can't imagine all the possible
histories that are